hey everyone how's it going my name is
miyuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about tech career and life
so i asked my twitch stream the other
day what video you all want to see and a
lot of you are interested
on what's on my mac i made a what's on
my iphone video a couple months ago and
so today i'm going to show you all of
the things that i use on my mac and how
i use it this will include mac
applications that i use on a day-to-day
basis as well as the functionality and
features of mac os
that i use all the time and yes it's mac
not pc
if you put a pc in front of me i
wouldn't know what to do with it because
i've used a mac since i was like
seven or something my dad was really
into apple computers from the early days
and so i've just kind of like
kept going with that and now look at me
i had a career as an ios developer
and i'm like fully in the apple
ecosystem at this point and just a
little background before we get started
i use the macbook pro i have the 15 inch
model because i bought it in mid 2018
before the 16 inch model came out
the processor is a 2.9 gigahertz 6 core
intel core i9 it's got 32 gigs of memory
and 1 terabyte of storage
when i bought it i wanted to do kind of
a lot of things i wanted it to handle
ios development super smoothly and also
video editing
so it's kind of like a souped up version
of a macbook pro
the next year up after this is probably
like an imac or imac
pro but i'm pretty happy with what i've
got right now so without further ado
let's dive in so the first thing i'm
going to show you are just features of
mac os that i really enjoy
using you may or may not know about them
but these are the ones that kind of have
made it into my workflow
so the first thing is do not disturb
mode there's a lot of notifications that
come flying through on my mac
and when i need a little bit of focus
time and i don't want to see what emails
are coming through or slack messages or
discord messages
then this is really handy also when i'm
like in a phone call on a zoom caller or
something then being able to silence
everything so that i am completely
focused on the task at hand
is something that has really helped me
to get my stuff done and right next to
do not disturb mode
is night shift now i used flux before
the invention of night shift on mac os
but it really does help me with my eyes
i have mine set to a schedule where i
have it turned
on at sunset and then turned on until
sunrise
i kind of like my scream to be a little
bit warmer like my eyes are already very
bad so they're doing a lot of work to
concentrate on a screen right in front
of me
and so taking away the blue light
definitely helps with my eyes so that i
can fall asleep at night
and i don't like blue light stuff
there's like a lot of competing debates
about it but really i have noticed that
since using night shift
i don't feel my eyeballs in my eyes when
i'm trying to fall asleep
and so i have night shift on my mac and
i also have it on my phone
and sometimes if my eyes are just tired
i'll just turn it on the middle of the
day like it really does just help
relieve my eye of that strain the next
thing i want to show you is
spotlight so unless you've changed the
settings on your own mac then you can
trigger spotlight with command
plus i have mine set so that'll search
through applications which really is
what i primarily use it for
and so instead of digging through like
the applications folder and trying to
find what you need
being able to go to spotlight search and
then type exactly what i need and then
press
enter and it launches thing makes it
super easy its origins are in something
called
alfred that a lot of people use at the
time that apple adopted and
it's made my workflow a lot easier and
it really helps you can have it set to
search through your different files as
well as different text
it can also even do math for you which
is really nice
uh and so that's just like a really
handy thing to have at your fingertips
another thing that i really like using
that's part of mac os is
spaces i have a lot of spaces all the
time and usually there's like an
application per space and i like this
because i like having full screen
windows for everything and it's easier
for me to navigate between different
spaces than it is
to navigate between different
applications so i usually have one for
video editing
another one for browsing the internet
another one for
text communication like discord and
whatsapp and i usually also have one for
spotify
i can always add more spaces i can also
take them away
and it's just been a good way to
organize all of my thoughts and the
applications that are running on my
computer
so those are the features that i enjoy
that are part of mac os
right now i'm using mac os catalina and
i'm really excited to use mac os big sur
as well as future releases to see what
functionality
apple adds to mac os while we're on the
topic of what's on my mac
i want to talk about one of my favorite
websites on my mac which is brilliant
who is a sponsor of today's video
brilliant is an amazing website and app
that makes learning super
accessible and fun their whole approach
is based on problem solving and
active learning which i think is really
kind of one of the best ways to learn
new things
they teach you concepts visually with
interactions to help you better
understand
and then also ask you questions so that
you're engaging with the topic
and content and unlike school there's
like no tests no grades
literally just to fulfill and enrich
your learning
they've got a ton of courses in math
science and computer
science one that i'm really interested
in that i'm going to take is the
knowledge and uncertainty course
this course gives you the mathematical
tools for dealing with the flood of
information in our lives
and you'll learn cutting edge
mathematics like information theory
bayesian networks and causal inference
but
in an accessible way without the
calculations getting in the way
they've also got a lot of great courses
in computer science as well
so whether you want to brush up on your
fundamentals and your algorithms or you
want to dive into something like python
or even cryptography
they've got it so try out brilliant
today by going to brilliant.org
hello myuco and only the first 200
subscribers will get 20
off the annual premium subscription
thanks so much for brilliant for
sponsoring and let's get back to the
video
so next we're going to talk about
applications so i have all of the
applications that i use on a day-to-day
basis
in my doc which shows and hides if i go
to the bottom of the screen
so we're going to start with brave brave
is a chromium-based browser that really
emphasizes privacy
it comes with built-in ad blockers and
everything and so it's been really
easy to use and i feel good using it
because it blocks all of these ads for
me to begin with
i actually used to use safari because
safari is also really good for privacy
but a lot of websites are built on top
of chromium and web developers are
mostly focused on delivering a good
experience on chrome and not so much
safari
which is why i've been using brave i
have my bookmarks at the top
and i have a couple of extensions but
that's
just that's kind of my web browser
there's not really a whole lot to it
there
so next let's talk about email i've been
using spark i use it on my phone and i
also
use the calendar for it as well i used
to just use the web browser for gmail
and then also the mail client on mac but
i needed something that was
a desktop app that also divided my email
just like how gmail does
i like that i can pin messages on spark
and that it divides my newsletters as
well as my notifications
and the calendar app's pretty intuitive
too there are some things that i don't
really like about
spark in that i can't completely make my
17
000 newsletters marked as read and i
don't think this email client is for
everybody
if there is like a more elegant solution
in the future that i enjoy using then i
think i'll hop to that but for now this
meets my needs
next we're going to talk about my
project management tools mainly click up
and trello
so i talked about both of these apps in
the video where i talk about how i
organize my life but these are the two
main things that i use to organize all
the tasks and projects that are going on
i really like that click up has a
dedicated mac app because then it
doesn't get lost in all of my browser
tabs
and it's really just easy to access it
does all the things that the web app
does
and i just kind of have it in a space
somewhere so that i can always look at
it if i need to
and in addition to click up i also use
trello so i use trello mostly for
projects that i'm working on with other
people and it's just a lot more
lightweight than click up and so for
simple projects it's been really good
to have this on hand next we're gonna go
into video editing things
so i use premiere pro i used to use
final cut but then i moved to premiere
pro because there's just a lot more
tutorials out there on how to use
premiere pro
and while the learning curve for adobe
products is always really big i feel
pretty comfortable with it now and it
does
all the things that i want it to and
more it's been really nice because i
also have the logitech mx keys and the
mx master 3
and so i've programmed my mouse and
keyboard with specific key bindings to
work
for premiere and that's really improved
my editing workflow it's made it so much
faster and it's a lot easier to edit
videos
so that's premiere next i'm going to
talk about figma so figma is a tool used
by designers
a lot of ui ux designers use figma or
sketch in order to create
mock-ups for apps and websites but i use
it mostly to create thumbnails and other
assets i might need for my videos and
content creation
so for instance i made all of my merch
on this as well as
all of my overlays for twitch and then
also assets for code with friends
it's pretty intuitive to use it's pretty
easy to collaborate with other people on
it
again i really appreciate it that it's
its own mac app because
i don't like using these heavy tools on
web because again it'll get lost in my
tabs or it's just not as efficient
and so being able to use it as a mac app
regardless of how it's built underneath
has been
a really good thing for my workflow all
right so next we'll talk about my coding
tool
so i'm an ios developer so literally
like the main
ide that i would use is xcode i have it
on my dock at the bottom
and if you're going to make ios apps you
have to use xcode
i don't really got a choice and so
yeah it's there right now i'm on 12.0.1
and yeah it's easy to access it's it's
how you
write apple apps and for everything
that's not ios development then i use
visual studio code
i've been through all the iterations of
going from sublime to
atom and it seems like now visual studio
code is like the de facto code editor
and i like it a lot i like that i can
add extensions to it the organization of
everything is really easy
being able to preview markup files has
been a real life saver as well
i'm not really a heavy user of visual
studio code because i'm not a web
developer but i know that a lot of web
developers like using this and it's a
really powerful product if you want to
use it that way
next on the dock we've got spotify
usually when i'm listening to music i'm
usually on spotify because that's where
all of my music is
spotify now next is notes so in the
video where i talk about how i organize
my life i talk about the various
note-taking systems that i have
and then notes app i use it as just kind
of like a note-taking dump
i use it as like a scratch pad really to
like copy paste
instagram captions as well as just like
quick to-do lists as well
and so just having a place that i can go
to to just like write something out
really fast right on my doc is why notes
is one of my most used apps on mac
honestly i should probably go and like
clear a lot of things out because
there's just a lot of
random notes in here that make zero
sense
so that's notes next i've got my slew of
communication tools
so i have messages on here so i can like
talk to my friends during the workday
i've also got discord because i have my
own server for people who watch my
twitch stream
and then i've got slack because i just
belong to i feel like so many different
and random slack groups and keep in
touch with folks every once in a while i
also have zoom down here because
our life is like on zoom nowadays since
we're in quarantine
and i use it at least once a day and
then i also have whatsapp mostly to
communicate with my brand manager
as well as people who live overseas and
lastly i've got lastpass which is my
password manager
just having it there so i can either
generate a new password or copy paste an
existing one
has made it super easy i also have the
chrome extension for lastpass as well
but that also deserves a spot on my dock
we're gonna skip over quicktime player
it's usually not in my dock but it's
there just because i'm recording my
screen right now
but next are the folders that i have and
in that i've got downloads
a lot of the stuff that i draw on my
ipad i airdropped my computer which then
lands and downloads and having this fan
out
view has been really easy to work with
because then i can just grab
things that have been downloaded to my
computer or airdropped i've also got my
dropbox folder because i put a lot of my
business things in there
and then i also have my videos folder
this just makes it super easy for when
i'm video editing and i need like a
quick asset or something it's just there
within reach
oh one last thing that i forgot for
keyboards i have the us english keyboard
and then i also have the hiragana
keyboard for when i type japanese
that's also up there so that's easy
within reach that i can
flip between the different languages
very quickly and that's it
thank you all so much for watching this
video i hope you liked it i hope you
found out about a new application or two
that maybe you'd consider using
let me know what features or
applications you like to use on your mac
in the comments down below and make sure
to subscribe to my channel if you'd like
to see more videos from me
and i will see you next time bye